bonjour à tous avec annie genevard donc
sommes très heureux de tenir ce point
presse nous sommes à 168 jours avant le
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle ça vous a pas échappé
la situation politique peut-être sans
doute résumé de manière très très simple
on a le sentiment aujourd'hui que le
président ne préside plus qu'il commente
on a le sentiment que le gouvernement ne
gouverne plus mais qu'au fond il le
commentent les commentaires du président
c'est une fin de règne qui va être très
longue pour la france et pour les
français
et cette fan règne constituer un
véritable abaissement de la vème
république
nous les républicains le premier parti
de france
nous avons une conception exigeante de
la vème république et cette conception
exigeante de la vème république nous a
conduit ces derniers jours à re lire
très attentivement l'article 68 de la
constitution l'article 68 de la
constitution dans un rédaction issue
d'ailleurs de la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 qui avait été
adoptée par le parlement réunions
congrès sur l'initiative du président de
la république nicolas sarkozy
l'article 68 de la constitution prévoit
la possibilité d'une procédure de
destitution du président de la
république en cas de manquement à ses
devoirs manifestement incompatible avec
l'exercice de son mandat
nous avons été très choqué de lire les
pseudos confidences du président de la
république française françois hollande
dans un livre
vous connaissez dont le titre d'ailleurs
est tout à fait signifiant c'est
confidences ses déclarations hasardeuses
pose un vrai problème institutionnel
lorsque le président de la république
déclare à des journalistes qu'il a donné
l'ordre de procéder un certain nombre
d'opérations spéciales
cette déclaration constitue à l'évidence
un grave manquement aux règles
protégeant le secret de la défense
nationale et c'est donc dans ce contexte
qu'un de nos collègues députés pierre
lellouche a préparé vous le savez une
proposition de résolution tendant à la
mise en oeuvre des dispositions de
l'article 68 de la constitution
je veux dire ici avec annie genevard au
nom des républicains que cette
proposition de résolution est une
initiative à la fois symbolique et utile
car elle pose une vraie question de
principe et nous serons de nombreux
députés républicains à la co signé
c'était le premier point deuxième point
ce matin je voudrais avec annie revenir
donc de propositions précises sur
l'actualité très préoccupante qui
concerne les forces de sécurité
intérieures les fonctionnaires de la
police nationale
les militaires de la gendarmerie
nationale mais aussi les fonctionnaires
des polices municipales mais aussi les
agents de la direction de
l'administration pénitentiaire
les agressions les attaques sauvages
dont sont victimes ses représentants de
la force publique sont extrêmement
préoccupantes ça traduit plus qu'un
qu'un climat ça traduit une mise en
cause de l'autorité de l'état et
nous avons dépensé de solidarité et de
respect à l'endroit de tous ces hommes
et de toutes ces femmes qui sont frappés
dans leur dans leur chair qui l'ont été
ces derniers jours et ces dernières
heures alors face à cela nous ne restons
pas les bras ballants et nous appelons
le premier ministre manuel valls le
mythe de l'intérieur bernard cazeneuve
et le garde des sceaux
jean jacques urvoas a un devoir d'action
ils sont au gouvernement ils ne doivent
pas se borner à une posture
compassionnel ils doivent être dans
l'action et nous nous sommes en
propositions c'est pour cela que je vous
annonce que cette semaine je dépose avec
eric ciotti est certain nombre de
députés républicains qui signeront ce
texte une proposition de loi renforçant
la répression des atteintes contre les
représentants de la force publique
instaurant une présomption de légitime
défense au bénéfice des policiers et des
gendarmes et tendant à réduire les
tâches indues de la police et de la
gendarmerie
c'est un texte qui comporte neuf
articles précis la peine applicable à la
destruction à la dégradation d'un bien
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un poste de police ou
de gendarmerie ferait l'objet d'une
circonstance aggravante première mesure
deuxième mesure la répression des
menaces proférées contre les policiers
les gendarmes ou toute autre personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique ainsi
que les menaces proférées à l'encontre
de l'entourage du conjoint des
ascendants descendants de ces agents
publics
cette répression serait renforcée
troisième mesure nous proposons
d'allonger la période de sûreté pendant
laquelle le condamné ne peut bénéficier
d'aucune forme de libération
conditionnelle ou mesures d'aménagement
de peine lorsqu'il s'agit de graves
agressions commises contre un policier
gendarme ou toute autre personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique et
quatrième proposition très forte est
absolument nécessaire de proposons la
création d'un mécanisme de peines
plancher pour la répression des
différents types d'agressions commises
contre les policiers les gendarmes et
les autres dépositaires de l'autorité
publique
nous proposons aussi d'ailleurs sur ce
cinquième point nous sommes
particulièrement contents parce que
d'être la quatrième ou cinquième fois
qu'avec eric ciotti nous dans cette
proposition depuis que nous sommes
député en 2012 proposant d'instaurer une
présomption de légitime défense au
profit des policiers des gendarmes
je précise d'ailleurs sur ce point qu'il
est vraiment temps que le gouvernement
ait un avis lorsque j'ai fait une
première proposition en 2012 débattu à
l'assemblée nationale le ministre de
l'intérieur manuel valls y était opposée
lorsque eric ciotti est revenu à la
charge
le ministre de l'intérieur bernard
cazeneuve s'y est opposé nous avons lu
grâce à vous grâce à la presse qu'il y
avait un début d esquisses de réflexion
à ce sujet que le gouvernement ferait
peut-être un jour en novembre des
propositions ces propositions nous nous
les mettons sur la table et nous
appelons tout simplement l'assemblée
nationale à les adopter
nous proposons aussi dans ce texte de
manière peut-être plus novatrices un
certain nombre de dispositifs qui
permettraient de renforcer le rôle des
agents de sécurité privés de manière
très encadrée
plus nous encadrerons et renforceront
les interventions d'agents de sécurité
privés par exemple pour des gardes
statiques ou pour des fonctions de
protection rapprochée plus nous pourrons
alléger le travail des policiers des
gendarmes et les libérer de ce qu'ils
appellent souvent à juste titre des
tâches indues voilà je je je tiens ce
texte à votre à votre disposition c'est
une initiative forte des républicains ce
natif concrètes initiatives
opérationnelles les mois qui viennent
doivent être utiles et nous avons bien
l'intention de continuer notre travail
de propositions qui est le propre d'un
grand parti de gouvernement
les républicains j'ai un dernier point
avant que annie ne vous fasse par
d'autres d'autres sujets tout aussi tout
aussi important pour pour nous nous
avons lu avec stupeur la résolution de
l'unesco du 13 octobre dernier qui au
fond ni le lien historique patrimonial
culturel identitaire entre le peuple
juif et sa capitale jérusalem c'est une
résolution de l'unesco qui choisit
d'appeler le mont du temple la mosquée
al aqsa qui choisit d'appeler le mur
occidental de jérusalem la place à le
bourg ac c'est un texte que la france
aurait dû rejeter l'abstention de la
république française lorsque cette
résolution a été débattu à l'unesco
cette abstention de la république
française est une faute
française est une honte
cette abstention de la république
française est une insulte à israël et
aux juifs de france
nous déplorons que le gouvernement
français est commis cette faute
nous le déplorons d'autant plus que nous
constatons que le gouvernement de la
république fédérale allemande comme le
gouvernement britannique ont eux choisi
à juste titre de voter contre cette
résolution honteuse de l'unesco et nous
appelons le président de la république a
présenté des excuses au fonds et surtout
à corriger à corriger
par d'autres votes par d'autres
initiatives
cette abstention tout à fait malheureuse
bien moi je voudrais évoquer à la proche
du 13 novembre
les cérémonies de commémoration qui vont
avoir lieu
et puis la réouverture du bataclan le 14
novembre qui a évidemment son poids de
symboles et qui est jeu supposé donner
un signe de confiance dans la vie dans
la culture alors un commentaire bien sûr
le recueillement sera de mise la
concorde nationale aussi mais les
républicains vite à ne pas s'enfermer
dans cette bulle commémorative
le combat doit continuer et doit
s'amplifier contre l'islam radical qui a
inspiré ces actes affreux qui ont causé
la mort de 130 personnes et blessé trois
cent cinquante autres alors des voix
s'élèvent continuent de s'élever pour
dénoncer le danger de l'islam radical
une des plus récentes se fait entendre
sur les ondes et dans les journaux ces
derniers jours ces dernières l heure il
s'agit de gilles kepel qui vient de
produire le livre la fracture et qui
alerte les politiques qui alerte les
responsables de la société française a
déjoué la stratégie d'enfermement dans
une posture victimaire des musulmans je
rappelle que et le sujet a été évoqué
aussi par des journalistes que vous qui
telles que renault de la villardière ont
dénoncé dans une émission qui a fait
grand bruit l'emprise de l'islam radical
sur la société française
image et preuves à l'appui alors je
rappelle que le danger il est bien là
lorsque l'on songe aux sondages
terrifiant qui a été produit il ya
quelques temps 50 % des 15 25 ans
considère que la charia passe avant les
lois de la république
ces chiffres nous doivent nous alerter
ça représente tout de même deux millions
de personnes et nous devons
impérativement continuer le combat
contre cette idéologie mortifère pour
notre pays pour notre république et dont
le danger continue de menacer
il y aura d'ailleurs dans la proposition
de loi dont guillaume larrivé vous a
parlé d éléments de réponse à à ce sujet
je voulais évoquer également à nouveau
la question des migrants avec le
démantèlement du camp de stalingrad
je suis maire député maire je suis vice
présidente de l'association des maires
de france et je comprends la colère des
maires d'île de france de toutes
tendances d'ailleurs comme françois
pupponi qui est un maire socialiste
comme des mères les républicains ou des
maires communistes qui se sont alarmés
des conditions dans lesquelles ils ont
vu arriver sur les ont vus arriver sur
le territoire de leur commune
des centaines de migrants sans avoir été
véritablement prévenu préparer il était
question de d'installer des centaines de
migrants dans des lieux qui sont
fréquentées par des scolaires comme les
gymnases donc manque de transparence
précipitations improvisations sont
dénoncés dans cette affaire et je crois
qu'il faut redire à quel point la
méthode choisie par le gouvernement qui
ignore les mères est proprement
insupportable je voulais évoquer
également le mouvement social des
infirmières
des hospitaliers un défilé est annoncé
mardi des filets au cours duquel ces
professionnels diront leur colère et
leur épuisement
il c'est une illustration d'un
renoncement de plus des engagements de
françois hollande qui avait promis en
2012 un pacte de confiance qui se voit
ainsi désavoué par des avoués pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord un plan
d'économie drastique de 3 millions
d'euros 3 milliards d'euros qui va
affecter le fonctionnement de l'hôpital
naturellement mais surtout et plus grave
encore ce plan d'économies drastiques ne
s'accompagnent pas des réformes
structurelles qui sont attendues par le
monde de l'hôpital et en particulier par
l' impuissance à enrayer une
bureaucratie tatillonne qui perturbe
énormément le travail des hospitaliers
tous les maires qui sont président de
leur conseil de surveillance le savent
les procédures se sont multipliées dans
des proportions qui sont à la fois
kafkaïenne est insupportable j'ajoute
que la suppression du jour de carence a
évidemment là aussi relancer
l'absentéisme dans la fonction publique
hospitalière qui avait déjà été très
mise à mal par la loi sur les 35 heures
enfin un mot sur le contexte budgétaire
vous savez que le parlement examine en
ce moment le projet de loi de finances
pour l'année 2017
et l'on voit en la matière
l'irresponsabilité du gouvernement à
l'oeuvre puisque les dépenses
s'accumulent elles se chiffrent à près
de 10 milliards d'euros par an de
dépenses nouvelles jusqu'en 2019
sans que l'on ait une idée précise de la
façon dont on les finance et l'objectif
de réduction du déficit sous la barre
des 3% s'éloigne inexorablement
voilà les quelques points que je voulais
évoquer ce matin en attendant de
répondre à vos questions
je complète ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure à propos de l'article 68 d'une
phrase nous avons trop de respect pour
la fonction présidentielle sous la vème
république pour accepter son abaissement
et c'est pour cela que l'initiative de
pierre lellouche est à la fois
symbolique et utile